supongamos que tenemos un campo
magnético ve que va de derecha a
izquierda
voy a poner algunas de las flechas de
este campo magnético de los vectores
pero nada más los que están aquí en la
pantalla va porque este campo está en
todo el espacio tridimensional entonces
también va de derecha a izquierda en el
fondo de la pantalla y más como por
donde estás tú bueno no voy a poner
tantas flechas para que no se amontonen
mi dibujo pero creo que te lo puedes
imaginar bueno además de este campo
magnético vamos a poner aquí un circuito
en realidad nada más va a ser un pequeño
cachito de circuito el resto del
circuito puedes imaginar que está por
allá arriba entonces aquí tenemos un
cacho de circuito y vamos a imaginar que
por aquí está pasando una corriente en
este sentido una cierta corriente que le
vamos a llamar lo vamos a llamar y va
entonces ahí está esa corriente aquí
está el lado positivo así que está el
lado negativo del circuito
entonces la corriente fluye hacia acá
además pensemos que aquí tenemos un eje
en el cual el circuito puede girar
entonces pues te quiero preguntar qué
crees que suceda que o sea cómo crees
que esta fuerza afecte a este circuito
bueno pues vamos a verlo entonces para
eso vamos a ir por cachitos primero
vamos a ver qué le hace la fuerza a esta
parte y luego a esta parte y luego a
esta parte y para eso vamos a recordar
cuál es nuestra fórmula la fórmula nos
dice que la fuerza que ejerce la voy a
poner más a la derecha porque ahorita
quiero hacer otra cosa por acá pero nos
dice que la fuerza
que ejerce el campo electromagnético ve
en un segmento del circuito es igual a
la corriente que está pasando por ahí
multiplicada por el producto cruz de la
longitud que nos interesa del circuito
con el campo magnético si esta es una
fórmula que ya vimos en vídeos pasados
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es estudiar
cachitos por cachito y nada más vamos a
fijarnos en la dirección a lo mejor
platicamos un poquito de la intuición
detrás de la magnitud pero empecemos con
la dirección entonces hacia donde nos
quedaría la fuerza que ejerce este campo
en este caso de acá en este primer
segmento que pues vamos a marcarlo en
color verde vamos a ponerle que va hacia
abajo y que es el ba entonces cuál sería
la fuerza o hacia dónde iría la fuerza
bueno para esto tenemos que utilizar la
regla de la mano derecha para ver este
producto cruz y hacia dónde tiene que ir
va entonces el dedo índice va en
dirección de la longitud que es hacia
abajo o sea iría más o menos hacia acá a
ver si me quede el dibujo creo que está
un poco complicado
pero bueno iría hacia acá hacia abajo
luego el dedo medio apuntaría hacia
dónde va el campo que es hacia la
izquierda no sé sería algo así porque se
dobla más o menos de este estilo y luego
va hacia acá y luego están por ahí los
otros dedos que quedan por aquí en medio
por aquí viene el dedo anular está el
dedo anular que luego lo interrumpe el
indique y el meñique viene para acá da
la vuelta y por ahí hace la muñeca aquí
se hace el otro cacho de muñeca está vas
a ver que queda un poco más padre
entonces por aquí está el meñique y aquí
se dobla el dedo bueno más o menos es la
idea sí entonces así está la mano está
apunta hacia abajo que es la dirección
de l verdad hacia la izquierda tenemos
la dirección debe y entonces hay que ver
hacia dónde apunta el pulgar pero el
pulgar quedó oculto detrás de todos los
dedos y eso justo indica que el pulgar
está apuntando hacia adentro para
entonces está apuntando hacia adentro
esto recuerda es una flecha que estás
viendo que que va hacia afuera de ti
entonces está
adentro y por lo tanto este campo ejerce
una fuerza que entra en la pantalla vale
entonces está empujando este segmento
hacia adentro bueno ya dije muchas veces
hacia adentro vamos con los otros
segmentos
vamos por ejemplo con este de acá en
este también pasa algo interesante y
este segmento es paralelo al campo
magnético entonces cuánto nos va a dar
este producto cruz pues cero verdad
acuérdate que el producto cruz justo
detecta qué tan perpendiculares son los
vectores o sea más o menos si alguna
componente de éste es perpendicular a
este de acá eso es más o menos la
intuición detrás pero aquí pues no son
nada perpendiculares verdad son
paralelos aunque van en direcciones
opuestas son paralelos y por lo tanto
del producto brush no va a detectar nada
y nos va a dar cero por ahí el seno del
ángulo es lo que lo que causa ese cero
bueno entonces aquí la fuerza no ejerce
el campo magnético no ejerce nada de
fuerza
voy a indicarlo así la fuerza
0 muy bien pasemos a este cachito de acá
déjame cambiar de color para variar un
poco entonces voy a utilizar este color
rosa en este caso de acá ahora la
longitud va hacia arriba porque
acuérdate que como por convención va en
la misma dirección que la corriente
entonces ahora utilizando nuestra regla
de la mano derecha
tenemos que apuntar hacia arriba con el
índice déjame ver si ven que el dibujo
hacia arriba con el índice hacia arriba
con el índice está tenemos que apuntar
este hacia hacia la izquierda con el
dedo medio por ahí está el dedo medio
más o menos y los otros dedos quedan
atrás dejando mi mano para ver cómo
queda más o menos
un dedo por ahí está el otro más o menos
por ahí está la palma y entonces hacia
dónde queda apuntando el pulgar pues
queda apuntando hacia arriba hacia
arriba hacia ti hacia fuera de la
pantalla entonces ahí está está
apuntando así hacia afuera
esto es una flecha que va hacia ti
entonces el campo ejerce una fuerza que
sale de la pantalla muy bien vamos a
reflexionar un poco qué sucede con estas
cosas para entonces qué pasa cuando
tenemos que del lado izquierdo tenemos
una fuerza que va hacia adentro y acá
una que está saliendo pues justo esto va
a ejercer un torque en nuestro circuito
acuérdate que por acá teníamos un eje
déjame déjame marcar el eje bueno déjame
poner
así una línea punteada para indicar que
ahí tenemos un eje entonces si
multiplicamos la fuerza a ésta que está
ejerciendo el campo magnético por esta
distancia por esta distancia obtenemos
un torque va entonces la fuerza por
distancia va a ser igual al torque y del
otro lado tenemos algo similar tenemos
aquí está aquí tenemos que estar
entrando y aquí tenemos que estar
saliendo va entonces en realidad estas
fuerzas pues no se cancela en verdad de
hecho colaboran entre sí para hacer que
esta cosa gire de esta forma sale pasa
por aquí en sí mitad y luego entra va se
entiende más o menos verdad espero que
sí bueno entonces vamos a ver cómo
quedaría rotado este este circuito
entonces pareció déjame tomar el color
amarillo vamos a girar lo
entonces ahora esto se va a ver un poco
más lejos lo voy a poner así en
perspectiva este va a quedar un poco más
cerca porque empezó a girar hacia afuera
va y déjame tomar la herramienta de
línea para completar estos cachitos en
este cachito se vería así este cachito
así más o menos en mis dibujos en
perspectiva pues no son los mejores del
mundo ahí están ahí tenemos que ya giro
si se ve más o menos la idea verdad aquí
está saliendo y aquí está como que
entrando y por eso se ve más grande y
más chico ok ahora qué sucede qué sucede
con este campo magnético y con el
circuito pues vamos a ver o sea la
corriente sigue fluyendo así aquí
seguimos teniendo más y aquí menos
entonces la corriente sigue fluyendo de
esta forma algo de este estilo vale el
campo sigue yendo hacia la izquierda
entonces podemos aplicar exactamente la
misma regla de la mano derecha para este
segmento para este de acá y para este de
acá para obtener las mismas direcciones
de la fuerza aquí tenemos que estar
entrando la fuerza y acá tenemos que
estar saliendo vale la fuerza está
la cala pues está saliendo pero qué
sucede ahora con el torque pues yo digo
que el torque es menor ahora el torque
es menor porque o sea la fuerza sigue
teniendo la misma magnitud sin embargo
ahora la distancia o sea y más déjame
poner un poco más en perspectiva ahora
la distancia está como hacia adentro y
hacia la izquierda va la distancia hacia
el eje de rotación pero va a ser menor
porque ya giro tantito entonces ahora
este lado está más cerca del eje de
rotación y por tanto va a ejercer menos
torque de este lado y lo mismo de este
lado aquí también nos acercamos y
también nos acercamos al eje de rotación
viéndolo en el plano viéndolo en el
plano este bueno en el plano de la
pantalla en este de acá entonces si vas
ir girando pero un poco menos fuerte y
si seguimos para están pensando en que
va girando y girando más entonces bueno
de todas formas tenemos una fuerza hacia
adentro de este lado y hacia afuera de
este lado sigue girando pero cada vez
tiene un menor
bueno pensemos que seguimos girando y
girando no hasta que lleguemos a que
giro ya 90 grados entonces tendríamos
una cosa de este estilo
esto puede ser un poco confuso pero pero
mira o sea este es el lado derecho
entonces este es el lado derecho
y el lado izquierdo ya no se ve porque
queda ya tránsito pero déjame nada más
pintar como por donde estaría como algo
de este estilo va entonces ahí está el
lado derecho y el lado izquierdo pero
ahora este ya quedó enfrente y en este
momento de aquí que pasa pues toda la
fuerza está actuando hacia abajo bueno
por la misma razón
digamos si nos fijamos en el lado que
está el fondo la fuerza está actuando
hacia fuera verdad en el que está dentro
está actuando hacia afuera entonces
ahora no va a ejercer nada de torque
porque no tenemos ninguna distancia al
eje al eje de rotación y lo mismo sucede
con este lado va sea el campo magnético
está haciendo que este lado vaya hacia
afuera porque la corriente está pasando
hacia abajo en este lado de acá en el
lado de enfrente pero como está
corriendo como la fuerza va hacia afuera
pues ahora no tenemos nada de torque
porque a través no hay nada de distancia
vale bueno entonces aquí ya no vamos a
ejercer nada de torque pero ojo puede
ser que este circuito todavía tenga un
poquito de momento angular y entonces o
sea estaba en esta posición empezó a
girar
garro como que cierta velocidad angular
y aquí todavía la atrae y entonces va a
pasarse tantito by entonces va a seguir
girando un poquito más de los 90 grados
entonces lo que te quiero dejar pensando
es que crees que pase una vez que
crucemos eso o sea ya que pasamos los 90
grados y empieza a girar tantito del
otro lado qué crees que suceda bueno te
voy a dejar pensando en ese acertijo y
practicaremos más al respecto en el
siguiente vídeo